right good morning everybody and welcome
to the employment committee I'm
councelor David Johnson I'm the chair of
this
committee um would committee members
um introduce themselves when they're
speaking your names will not appear on
the screen are you all right over there
councelor or goody
um we've been broadcast live and as
we've just been saying
there must be a mass audience out there
um waiting for us to proceed um we have
some
apologies we have apologies from
councilors Parry Rock and
shinton uh do any committee members have
any interest that they would like to
declare in relation to any items on the
agenda no thank you
chairman David Buck chief executive can
I make a a declaration on behalf of all
staff obviously we are employees the
council and the pay policy effect us
it's not a a pecuniary interest but I
just wanted to make that point Thank you
thank
you the minutes have been circulated are
there any points members wish to
raise Council
juned Susan juned um just that when
things go do go ahead that for example
um some of the um you know the actions
like the gardening club Etc goes goes
ahead could we have a a report back when
that happens I'd be very
interested did we not agree in the
council paper on staff strategy to
receive regular
Reports say some more through you chair
yes yes absolutely um we're in the
process currently of just um agreeing
the action plan that goes to management
team next Thursday once that's agreed
then it will come regularly twice a year
to employment committee so that you'll
see the updates on where we are thank
you any other
points otherwise I'll sign the minutes
as a true record of what took
place so can we move on to the
substantial item of the day the pay
policy
statement and could I invite Mr Doan to
uh present the
report thank you chair um Lea Doan HR
manager so the purpose of the paper
today is um for you to look at the
annual pay policy statement so the last
13 years since 2011 the localism ACT has
required us to publish certain
information relating to pay and
remuneration particularly of our senior
officers we published our first annual
report in 2012 13 and we have done so
annually off um ever since um the report
comes to you as employment committee
first um but then has to be signed off
finally by full
Council so there are a number of things
that are required as a matter of Statute
to be covered within the pay policy
statement and if I refer you to point
1.3 of the report that is the level and
elements of remuneration for each chief
officer the remuner remuneration of its
lowest pay
employees relationship between Chief
officers and other officers pay and all
other aspects of Chief officers
remuneration you will see from the
statement which I'll I'll come to in a
moment um that actually we go above and
beyond that um and include everything
relating to paying remuneration um for
all officers the other thing that we're
required to do is publish pay multiples
and so if I refer you to 1. six of the
report um and my chair has pointed out
to me today uh my glaring error in
1.6.1 in that both of those dates should
be 2024 not
2023 and again in the heading for 1.7
that should be 2024 25 not 23 24 but in
1.6.2 you will see the ratios that um
that we're required to
publish um this is a document which is
um updated every year there are no new
items of policy for the committee to
agree and I just wanted to take you very
quickly through the changes um just so
that you can be reassured that they are
um just matters of um update for each
year so firstly um 3.7 of the
statement gives the pay
award upgrade for all
staff on to
4.1 the whole of that point again
updates the actual salaries that were
impacted by that pay award and point C
of that um particular Point updates the
number of service managers at each
particular
grade in
4.2 um at the bottom of the first
paragraph We had a review of the
management team salaries on the 11th of
April 2020 23 some of you may recall
that so I've added that in in addition
in the next paragraph to the pay award
for chief offices which was an increase
of
3.5% last year with all um pay awards
for all groups we at the stage for 20242
where negotiations are about to commence
shortly we're waiting for the union um
pay claim and then that will commence so
um as usual it's unlikely that that will
be in place for the 1st of April um and
these things often take a little bit
later often into the Autumn and then
backdated awards are made
accordingly um
4.10.1 just an update that the returning
officer has now um reverted to the chief
executive um those who were here last
year will remember that David Dolby held
that post for a little while and then if
I refer you to
4.10.2 the second paragraph last year we
had seven Chief officers who were still
receiving a car lease contribution um
with natural wastage that has now gone
down to two and you'll be aware that
that scheme has been frozen for many
years and we're just letting um letting
those run their course 4.10 the
contribution bands have been
updated um again they they're always
slightly behind but we're 23
24 um and that is it new grading
structure with the updated salaries in
appendix one and um the updated
structure chart in appendix 2 which of
course shows our two new heads of
service Marcia Reon and Annette Homer
who have taken place since last we spoke
on this subject so I will finish there
and I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you Council juned uh Susan juned
just just a query actually um on
3.5 um we there is mention there about
about um cost of housing in the district
and the impact on uh Recruitment and
Retention is that still an issue um that
you're finding here in in this District
that Recruitment and Retention because
of high housing costs is a problem or is
it something that has actually um
resolved
itself if I can respond to that chair I
think the situation where Recruitment
and Retention is more complex now than
it used to be um certainly at the time
when we um we did the job evaluation and
single status process which was 2005 um
the housing market was one of the main
issues around recruitment I would say
now that's broadened um as you know
we've discussed before the general
issues within the market in terms of um
terms of recruitment but the housing
market in the area remains High um and
we remain having a large number of our
staff who don't live within Stratford
Town itself and live either within our
um outer Ling Villages such as old
shipston or even you know over into um
witch Haven and redit with um eam redit
proms Grove those sorts of areas um so I
don't think it's changed but I think in
terms of recruitment the issue has
broadened any other comments Council W
hoggins yeah Council Wy hoggins just to
say so you've mentioned about the the
the broader issues for recruitment I
wonder if you'd like to elaborate a
little bit on that um Mr domain so that
we can see uh just get a picture really
of what we're facing as far as
employment is concerned to the council
thank
you if I can reply chair and I'm sure my
chief executive might want to to add
some some extra bits and pieces um we
are and across the sectors all
struggling with recruitment at the
moment we are particularly struggling um
with um with two areas so firstly our um
local government professions so we're
struggling to recruit but we're also
struggling to compete with the private
sector for those professions which span
sectors so those more generic areas um a
good example would be um solicitors
we're finding it incredibly difficult to
appoint solicitors um what we've found
since um the pandemic is that our USP
which we'd always had here at Stratford
of um being extremely flexible around
working Arrangements which many of our
professional staff said well we're we're
happy to come and commit to local
government we understand that the
salaries maybe don't compare with the
private sector but there are other
benefits which benefit us greatly since
the pandemic where the whole world has
now learned that you can actually work
from home and work in a hybrid way that
is no longer something which is unique
to us um and so there are a variety of
different issues and um as you know the
staff strategy has just been approved by
Council and we've got a number of tasks
in there to look at how we sell
ourselves how we Market ourselves how we
enhance our benefits both financial and
non-financial um to attract the best
people that we
can Ju Just Just a comment further on
that particular Point um we had this
discussion last time when we talked
about the staff strategy and and one
issue that when management team have
looked to prioritize the action plan
something that also Unison are in favor
of is prioritizing that development of
an apprenticeship scheme for the council
to grow our own where we've had
difficulties in recruiting staff we have
been successful in in training staff to
undertake those functions so we we we
are bringing that forward in the first
quarter of 2004 uh
2425 councelor Parker we've um we're in
the middle of the pay policy statement
discussion
um the machine isn't working very well
if you speak if you could just say who
you are for the benefit of thank you
Duncan Parker and apologies chair for
being
eight any further questions or
comments in which case can we move to
the
resolution could I have the
resolution is on
page there we are on
page policy statement be am as appended
to this report be adopted for the period
five proposer C Susan janett I would
like to propose it second councel W
Hawkins all those in
favor anyone
against anyone
abstaining thank you so that's passed
um sorry that's
recommended correction that is
recommended for for Council to consider
[Music]
um so I'm not aware of any other urgent
business
so members would note that the date of
the next meeting has moved from you've
been informed but it's moved from the
12th of March to the 26th of
March so thank you for attendance and uh
I'll conclude the
meeting